moi ce que je retiens de cette affaire
c'est que cette bombe explose à un
moment crucial sur le continent tout
d'abord elle mais l'allemagne face à ses
propres contradictions dans la sphère du
gaz nord stream une partie du monde des
affaires et des institutions donc porte
ce dossier une autre très atlantiste et
très pro otani à l'américaine et contre
celle ci évidemment sur la même longueur
d'onde que les états unis autour de
l'allemagne il ya un certain nombre de
pays qui sont très anti russe et qui eux
ne veulent absolument pas du gazoduc non
pas parce qu'ils sont anti russe
finalement mais parce qu'il ne
toucherait plus les subsides qui touche
grâce aux gazoducs terrestres qui
approvisionne l'europe ça voilà c'est du
côté du continent on voit aussi que
cette affaire explose au moment où la
campagne américaine reprend d'ailleurs
je note que peu trop au passage a dit
qu'on n'avait pas encore des preuves
d'un empoisonnement donc il est assez
prudent trump on attend de voir quelle
sera la réaction de maiden et qu'est ce
qui se passe en france on voit et madame
la crau qui est assez gêné finalement
aux entournures
cela pose question sur le positionnement
en fait de la france vis-à-vis de la
russie et vis-à-vis de ses partenaires
et effectivement la complexité est très
difficile à démêler qui a le meilleur
intérêt à ce que cette crise perdure que
ce soit l'otan je suis pas certain les
orgas internationales ne sont pas
toujours est loin d'être capable de
gérer des affaires nationales et des
intérêts nationaux donc une méfiance
effectivement mais que ce soit
directement liée à l affaire dont nous
parlons je n'en suis pas sûr maintenant
il ya un problème de dépendance du gaz
ces deux réalités et avec différents
acteurs la complexité je suis un cas pas
aujourd'hui de vous dire qui est le réel
coupables réels acteurs derrière qui
tire les ficelles
c'est un ensemble maintenant il faut
garder raison et puis finalement pendant
un peu de recul un peu de calme et voir
un petit peu dans le temps comment les
choses vont se dérouler